I was breathing into a paper bag I was
like Jesus Christ how am I gonna get
through this walk about two Gamow of me
joshing too nice and stay with joined by
two queens of the universe that's not
good enough er yeah
I'm seal of this movie there's two
really strong women in X finger-licking
good when you wash it back were you like
oh my god yes girls I was like I am so
good like you know your way around a
killer boss [ __ ] saved more your tips
so giving a boss a slip would you say a
boss come on oh I see here's the thing I
don't think you need to show everything
in order to be sexy in a suit so like
you know button the thing up to here I'm
so sick of men wearing suits where their
nipples are and their crotches are on
display like mints or gentlemen we don't
need to give away the farm I still want
to buy the milk
okay now YouTube bassy spend your whole
time in this movie trying to assess each
other what your top tips about sizing
each other in real life like I would say
like Tonya Harding is the approach just
like you know do it a little bit learn
from her mistakes yes you know like hire
somebody hire a professional don't make
it somebody who's can be tied to you you
know now ultimately this is an elaborate
revenge plot drama what would you say to
me if I want to wreak revenge on my
exploits
I actually do have a friend who slashed
his boyfriend's tie no way really
oh that's amazing but like but like did
it in like Oh like not in like a crazy
way so like he just thought oh they're
not razenoid especially tires I've
always said if I was gonna turn four to
women it would be you two
at the same time ideally well we're a
package deal so we're glad you're on
behind so how'd you guys like gear your
South up for the kissing scene get me
like into a paper bag I was like Jesus
Christ how am I gonna get through this
for more videos like this subscribe here
for glamour UK
[Music]